- [Eitav] Hello everybody.
So glad to see you today.
Who is having a good time so far?
- Woo.
- Yeah.
- Woo!
- Exactly.
This is the spirit.
So today we're going to talk about
how to manage bots versus humans
using Amazon CloudFront and AWS WAF.
My name is Eitav Arditti.
I am an Edge specialist at AWS,
meaning I work on a daily basis
with different Edge customers
and seeing the different
patterns out there.
And lucky enough, I was Edge
customer for the last 10 years.
So I am very happy to share
my experience today with you
and later on to discuss
your own challenges.
Together with me on the stage is Nick.
- [Nick] Hi everybody.
Nick McCord, Startup Solutions Architect.
So my day job is working with startups
and what I chose to do was
working with services that are
around going global in minutes.
I just thought the concept
of that was interesting.
So I've helped dozens of
customers of all sizes
with their CDN, WAF, and DDoS problems,
as well as published a few
blogs and AWS solutions.
- [Eitav] Cool.
So a bit of the operations here,
this is considered as
a Code Talk, level 300.
So what does it mean?
We're going to deep dive.
So yes, we're going to
have a quick short ramp up,
but during the entire
session this is going
to be quite a complex concept
so we'll try to face
it during the session.
But if you have any questions during it,
we'll have some time after this session.
We're going to present a lot of code
and architecture diagrams.
During the entire session,
both Nick and myself will
have a live demo running
to showcase how the different
changes within CloudFront
and WAF actually implemented
and actually impacted our
platform that we built for you.
And last Q and A, so
this session is recorded
so we're not going to do a
Q and A during the session,
but both Nick and myself will be here
for the next 15 minutes after the session.
So please reach out later on
and we'll be happy to discuss.
So after the operation,
we can start discuss
about our topic for today.
So humans, who of those
know humans? (laughs)
I surely hope that's all
of us here are humans,
but nowadays it's quite
challenging to understand.
So when all of us trying
to build the products,
we aim to build it for humans
to the actual legitimate users
that will use our product.
But since the internet began,
we also saw a tremendous
trend of using of good bots.
Good bots are usually being
used to operate the internet,
to crawl the index, to
populate our websites,
and eventually are good for our business.
But wherever there is
good there is always bad.
And this time we have bad bots.
So bad bots can also try to
harm your infrastructure.
DDoS is the most common
attack that we see out there,
but bad bots can also
try to replicate your IP,
try to steal your content
and maybe publish it somewhere else.
So we'll discuss about
those two in the session.
And last, we must say AI in
every single session, right?
So AI bots
and we see an increased trend
in the last two years of AI bots.
And this is like tweaking,
because this is combining all
the human, bad and good bots.
Some of those AI bots,
those agents are working for humans,
but some of them are just trying
to showcase they are humans.
So in today's session we're going
to discuss about all those four topics
and as promised a quick Edge ramp up.
So Amazon CloudFront footprint
is the Amazon CDN service
that's mostly is being discussed
when you're talking about Edge.
So Amazon CloudFront is built
from more than 700 point of presence
that we like to call
POPs around the globe.
So no matter if you want
to serve a cache content,
which is usually being used with CDN,
but also if you want to serve your APIs
closer to the actual customers,
we see a lot of customers
using Amazon CloudFront.
And in this specific session
we're going to talk
about Amazon CloudFront,
Amazon CloudFront Functions,
and AWS Lambda@Edge,
which is our compute Edge offering at AWS.
We're going to discuss about AWS WAF
as the protection layer
on top of CloudFront
and last we're going to
talk about Amazon CloudWatch
as a unified observability
service to showcase
the entire changes during this session.
- [Nick] Thank you.
Shall we make all of these
services work together?
Well, I think a good place to start
is going to be breaking down
the journey of the request,
which falls into four different stages.
The first is going to
be the viewer request,
which before the request even
hits the CloudFront cache
is going to be evaluated
against your AWS WAF rules,
which is the protection
logic you have in place
broadly across your site,
but more specifically for your Edge cache.
Next we have our origin request.
This is often commonly
referred to as a cache miss
and this will happen if the content
that the user has requested
is not in the cache
or if the TTL and time to live has expired
and needs to be refreshed.
So CloudFront makes the
request on your behalf
to your designated origin,
which then responds
with an origin response.
This populates the CloudFront cache,
which can then be used
for the viewer request
and for subsequent requests
from viewers that come in.
This has the advantages
of being more latency advantages
as well as a better cost profile.
In addition to this, we have access logs.
This is using CloudWatch,
Kinesis, Firehose and S3.
This is going to be
capturing different aspects
about the request once it's
been sent back to the user.
This can include the total processing time
of this entire flow.
It could be different
headers, query strings,
the various fields and aspects
that are being captured
by CloudFront for each of them,
as well as real time logs,
which is gonna be making
use of a Kinesis data stream
and is actually going
to give you those logs
in seconds as opposed to the minutes
that you would see with standard logs.
This can be further filtered down
so that you're using sampling
or doing it on specific
behaviors or caching policies
so that you don't have the additional cost
of all of your logs
being ready immediately
if you don't need it.
Moving more deeply into WAF,
here we have a protection pack,
formerly known as Web ACL.
If any of you have updated
to look at the new UI,
and this is going to be the
scaffolding for our rules,
our rule groups, everything
that we want to do
with layer seven protection using WAF.
We have various protected resources.
All of these are accessible through HTTP.
This could be your API endpoints,
could be your Kognito user groups,
but compatible with various services.
And then the smallest unit within AWS WAF
is going to be a rule.
And so this is going to house
business logic and an action.
The business logic could
be geo-based IP rules.
You could be looking at query strings.
It's really gonna be
dependent on your workload,
what you want to evaluate,
and what you want to
protect about your workload.
These rules can then be
bundled up into a rule group
and what this does is allows you
to have portability
across different web ACLs
or protection packs
in order to make it a little bit easier
in terms of managing the overhead of rules
across multiple different
WAF protected resources.
It's important to note
that these are in priority.
So if you hit a terminating
rule on your rule one
and you either block
or allow that request,
then rule two and the rule group here
is not going to be evaluated.
So it's important to think about
what you want that flow to be.
What are the, let's say IPs,
or the the regions that
you wanna block outright
and you don't wanna have any
more advanced evaluation of?
Versus the ones that need to go through
that entire workflow.
So how this ends up
looking is for your user,
they should be passing seamlessly through,
it works every time.
They're never going to have
an interruption in production impact.
Threat actors are going to be constantly
trying to navigate around this,
which is why WAF is considered something
that's not set and forget.
You have to continually evaluate the rules
that you're adding to your WAF.
You have to look at the
behaviors that are coming in
and then make updates to these.
Amazon does help with that.
We have our manageable
groups for common use cases
such as IP reputation lists
or the OS top 10, which
is in our core rule set.
But this is a constant journey
where you're going to be evaluating
and understanding what is
actually hitting your workload.
So a bit of background.
How many animal people do
we have in the audience?
A few. Okay, okay.
Fellow animal lovers.
This will play I promise.
So we built a platform out for animals
and this is largely driven
by the 2024 ASPCA report
where 5.8 million dogs and cats in rescues
and shelters for the year.
I know we say a lot of
big numbers at re:Invent,
so I'll put that in a
little bit of context.
If you were to adopt a dog
every hour for 662 years,
then you'd get to that number
or fill about a hundred NFL stadiums.
So quite a few.
Additionally, the data
shows the length of time
in shelters and rescues is increasing.
And last year alone they
euthanized over 600,000 animals.
Now why are we qualified to do this?
I've been an extensive
participant in fostering.
We both are rescue dads
and as Eitav mentioned,
it would not be re:Invent
without a little bit of AI.
So the dogs are much closer.
It probably could have
done a better job on us.
So what we ended up doing
is building out a platform
for aggregating this data
from the rescues and shelters.
Our platform is far better
because we have these relationships.
It's more up to date.
We have a larger pool of
animals than you can find
directly with the shelters and rescues.
Just to switch over to the UI.
Here, we have basic search functionality.
So you can look for a particular pet type,
you have maintenance level.
For some reason I continually find
the high maintenance ones.
(Eitav chuckles)
You have the max age.
And then for demonstration purposes
we have added a bot toggle.
So this is basically to
differentiate between the experience
a bot is going to have on our website
versus a legitimate human,
as well as an admin panel
where we can see logs
on the adoption requests
that are being submitted
and logs that are coming
in from CloudFront.
Swap back over here.
So we got a whole bunch
of adoption requests.
Our platform's a huge success.
Awesome, well, wait a second.
We have adopters being
numerically incremented
and it appears that there's
someone that's trying
to take advantage of the data that we have
and they are saturating
our adoption pipeline
with these fake adoption requests.
So as much as we might think
this is the outcome of that,
more than likely there is
another competitor in the market
that is going to be taking this data
and doing it for profit as
opposed to the non-profit
that we are operating as.
So to summarize, we've got
our pet adoption platform,
tons of traffic, but only
certain pets are being adopted.
And we operate off three main KPIs,
which we'll continue to come back to.
The first is going to be website traffic.
The second is the application review time.
We have a healthy bench
of adoption reviewers
and then finally is going
to be the time to adopt.
Well, now what do we do?
AWS Edge to the rescue.
So QR code, you're welcome
to play along with us.
You all mostly look human,
but for demonstration purposes
we are going to assume you're bots.
So as we're going through
the different phases,
you're going to see the
experience that is reflective
of a bot that is going
to be hitting our site.
So you'll see how that plays out.
On the backend,
Eitav and I are going to
be helping each other out
with AWS CDK.
So we'll be doing
deployments to automate this,
but I'll be walking through the console,
show you just how easy it is
to do some of these very simple steps
and into some of the code
that applies to the functions.
We did use a little help.
We've set up a pretty
sophisticated bot using Tor Cannon
and that is going to be
both manufacturing traffic to our website,
makes the graphs a little bit prettier,
but it'll also demonstrate
some of the complex nature of bots
that you'll end up potentially
seeing with your business.
So what's our baseline architecture?
Very straightforward.
S3 object for storing the animal images.
This is going to go to our cache.
If it's a new pull, then we
need to repopulate the cache.
For the adoption requests,
this is going to go to our load balancer
backed by serverless AWS Lambda.
And then we have a Dynamo DB
for storing those adoption requests.
So if we look where it
stands right now, no WAF.
If you take away one
thing, it's adopt a dog.
I'm just kidding. Turn WAF on.
So we go over here
and we look at where our phase starts.
We have a good bit of
traffic that is coming in
and there you'll notice
that the number of CloudFront requests
and the amount of adoption
requests is all very linear.
So these are unable to be distinguished
between humans and bots at the moment
and we aren't doing
anything to protect it.
So phase one, let's turn on WAF.
What does that look like though?
As we are going to add rate limiting,
which is based on a
timeframe that you specify,
can be down to as low
as I believe, a minute,
and then up to several.
This can be based on URI, IP headers.
There's a bunch of different
aspects within the request
that you can use to actually,
as the counter for the rate limiting.
In addition, we're using
JA3/JA4 fingerprinting.
This is around SSL, TSL, TLS connections.
It's a hash created by a combination
of the request characteristics
and it's very helpful for
catching subtle tricks
of a request manipulation
as opposed to looking just at
the geo where it's coming from
just at the IP or the user agent.
And then finally, bot control.
Amazon does have a managed
rule group for this.
It comes in two flavors
of common and targeted.
This is functions by monitoring,
blocking and rate limiting,
scrapers, scanners, crawlers, SEO.
How it does this is as the
requests are going through
that WAF pipeline of rules
that we talked about,
it adds labels to it.
So it's you can label the good bots,
the SEO that you want to crawl
versus the ones that it deems to be bad.
So what does this look like
in our new architecture?
We now have WAF coming in
and to walk you through
kind of the pseudo logic
that exists before we
get into the console,
we have request comes in,
WAF is checking,
"Hey, are you a bot? No."
Otherwise humans can progress on through.
So we swap over
to what this looks like in the UI.
Here we have our CloudFront distribution,
oh, the burden of being tall.
And you can see when it comes up
that we have a WAF attached,
but right now it's not blocking anything.
So we're going to do a very simple change
of going over to our managed rules.
We have the IP reputation list,
we have rate limiting here,
bot control, add bot label.
We have made it easy for ourselves
and consolidate all of these
to basically add a label to the request,
which we then act on at the end.
So that's the take action here
and we're going to go over
and change it from count to block.
Save rule.
And so now if we go over to our UI,
I'm a normal human,
I can keep searching for all
of the pets that I would like,
and then a bot.
Oh no. (laughs)
Now any thoughts on how this
might reflect in our logs?
Well, if it's a simple bot,
they'll just give up
and find a new target.
However, ours are a bit craftier.
So if we go into what this
has done for WAF blocking,
we've actually seen an increase
in the amount of requests.
So what we've said is that for the people
that are using bots on our website,
they have detected that
they are being blocked
getting the four hundreds
and they're trying alternative methods.
Trying alternative methods
and what that means is
they're using different request types,
they are using different paths,
they're saturating across
a different number of IPs,
and bot blocking.
Is it blocking?
- [Eitav] It should be.
- [Nick] Hmm, may take a moment.
We do have a prep though over here.
So we see the CloudFront requests go up
so it sees it's blocked
and they're trying harder.
They're not gonna give up easily.
What this is actually doing is
we have more traffic flowing,
which is a greater cost to us.
We have more requests
that are being submitted
and it's harder for us to track.
So we've actually made it a
little bit more expensive for us
to be able to do this.
And then how does this impact our KPIs?
So we have an increase in website traffic
but not in a good way.
We have application review
time which has been increased
because they're still trying to do it
and then the time to adoption
hasn't really changed.
So how can we be smarter
as the implementers of the WAF logic?
Well, instead of giving them the,
hey, you're not allowed
here, very clear stop sign,
we can change from using
terminating actions of block
to non-terminating.
There are CAPTCHAs and challenge,
which some of you may be familiar with.
We are specifically gonna be using count
and then we're going to enhance that
by adding a custom request
header to those requests
that are coming in and deemed to be bots.
So a bot's going to come in,
we'll add a header to it,
and then make use of a caching policy
so that if that request
is deemed to be a bot,
we are only gonna show it
a segment of our platform.
This way we can narrow down
the amount of animals
that are being scraped
and we have control over what
is being pulled from our site.
This makes it less
valuable data to the bot.
What does this look like
in the architecture?
We now have two different paths.
The request comes in
and instead of outright blocking it,
we are going to add the X
is bot true else do nothing.
And then as it goes through
and hits our caching policy,
the bot is going to be redirected
to our CloudFront cache.
So swapping over here.
Off that, we are going to
look at our distribution.
Right now we have the
different caching behaviors.
We are going to our search
path pattern and edit.
We've pre-configured the bot policy here.
So if we take a look at that policy,
we can see the different
aspects of the query strings.
That's a part of it.
I get to copy this.
Amazon WAF is going to preface the headers
that are added as part of these WAF rules
with the X Amazon WAF.
And we go back over here,
this is going to be saved
to our distribution.
And then in the WAF rule for our action,
instead of blocking here,
we'll move over to count
and do a custom request.
So now if we go back
to what the experience
for a bot looks like,
humans still have access.
Swap over to a bot, they have access,
but the same access, I can
keep searching, keep searching,
and it's gonna be the same
content that the bot is getting.
Whereas if I'm a human,
I can see hamsters,
I can see bunnies,
I can see all of the available
animals on our platform.
So now we've restricted the bot,
what the bot is able to see
only to a much smaller portion.
What does this mean for our KPIs?
Well, overall the deploy changes go down.
The cloud run requests go down.
The WAF blocked traffic,
there is none anymore that's blocked.
And our Lambda invocations have decreased.
Website traffic is now at an acceptable
and appropriate level
for what we would expect for our platform.
Our application review time,
we can work with the
volunteers to say, hey,
this segment of animals is
the ones that are in the cache
and are going to have
known bad adoption forms.
And then the time to adoption
for a vast majority of
our animals has decreased.
- [Eitav] So while those are great metrics
and improvement in our application,
does it actually impact
what we try to solve?
So if I go back to our platform
and repeating what Nick just mentioned,
where humans get new pets every time,
but bots get the same pet,
this is going to put us
in a different challenge
because now bots getting
the same cache response
and they'll probably try to adopt
the same pet over and over again.
So we just moved the problem
from hitting all the different pets
to hit on a specific pet.
And both Nick and myself
love all the pets.
So we need to find a way and solution
to somehow don't impact any of
the pets during our research.
So we are going to present
couple of more approaches,
couple of more approaches
on how you can customize
even further the traffic,
the bot traffic.
So we believe that different traffic
deserves different response
and we're going to use
a couple of concepts
within CloudFront and WAF
that will help us provide
different response to bots
but still doesn't signal back to the bots
that they're being blocked.
So first we're going to
use origin modification.
Origin modification is quite a new feature
within CloudFront Functions
that allows you to override
the traffic from one origin
to a different origin.
This is usually being used for AB testing
where you want to split the traffic
between different regions.
But this can all also be used
if you got a signal from
upstream like the WAF upstream
and route the traffic to
the different regions.
Moreover, we're not just going to reroute
the bot traffic to a new region,
we're going to traffic to a new region
that we used an honeypot on it.
So instead of just responding
with a different pet,
we want to respond with
an intelligent response
that will allow us to get more
insights about the attackers
and maybe understand why
it tried to attack us,
and last, we are going to use
a cache busting mechanism.
So Nick implemented a caching for bots,
meaning bots going to get the
same over and over response.
But these have some caveats
because if you're going to response
for bots from caching only,
you are going to lose the
insights about the bots.
So using CloudFront Functions,
we're going to implement
a way to override some
of the caching policies
and control it according
to your business logic.
So in our example,
we're going to cache busting
for only 1% of the traffic,
but you can do it for as
much percentage you need.
So many of those features
are related to CloudFront Function.
So we're going to do
a couple minutes 101 on
CloudFront Functions.
So CloudFront Functions
are a lightweight compute
running on the Edge
and this is basically a
simple JavaScript file
that you can write
and it will run between
the WAF and to your region,
meaning at first the WAF happens
and only then the CloudFront Functions.
This is allow us to read the
headers that WAF is adding.
So the CloudFront Functions
are based with, as I mentioned,
a simple JavaScript.
So you can use variables
like stream and numbers.
You can define your own functions.
You can create, you can use
JavaScript native methods
such as split, length, lowercase,
and other many JavaScript native methods.
You can use more advanced methods
like buffers and crypto if you want
to create your own
authentication within the Edge.
And you can also do as in
corporation using Promise
and asking to wait.
And of course every JavaScript program
should support console log.
So every time that you
are doing console log
within CloudFront Functions,
it will auto ship to
CloudWatch logs in USC one.
So you can later on check those logs
and you control the return.
So the control of the
return is quite important.
So if you return and request object,
this tells CloudFront
to just proxy the request
later on to the origin.
But if you return the event dot response
that we'll see in a second,
this will tell CloudFront
Functions to terminate the request
and skip the origin altogether.
So if you want to do a very quick blocking
on the Edge after the WAF,
you can do it using CloudFront Functions.
So the event structure, we
discussed a bit about the event.
So we have the context
and this is like a general
metadata of the distribution.
So we have a request ID,
this is CloudFront request ID
and this is unique per request.
We have the distribution
ID and the event type.
So CloudFront Functions can be hooked
to the viewer request
and the viewer response.
So you can write your own code
according to the different viewing type.
We have the viewer within the event
and this is basically the device
that's got connected to CloudFront.
In the vast majority of the cases,
it will be our mobile devices,
our laptops or the server to server.
And this will represent the
actual IPs of those devices.
We have the request and the
request is also modifiable,
meaning you can also
read the query string,
the headers and the cookies,
but you can manipulate those
using CloudFront Functions.
And as same as the request,
we'll also have the response
when we can manipulate
the status code, status
description, headers, cookies,
and override the body altogether.
And as I mentioned before,
this is quite important
to understand if you want
to terminate the request
or just proxy to the origin.
In order to use origin modification,
we are going to use a new helper
that you should use the import CF
from CloudFront in your own code.
This helper allows us
and exposes three different method to us.
The first one is update origin,
sorry, update request origin.
And this allows you to override
any kind of origin
parameters like the host,
the entire URL, the editor,
the TLS configuration.
You can simply override whatever you need.
So this will allow us later to route
between bots and human origin.
You can also use the select
request origin by ID.
So you can deploy pre-made
entire origin configuration.
So you're just stating the
ID that you want to use
and it will auto import the
configuration from there.
And you can also use our
request origin groups,
which gives you a native
failover mechanism.
Within the region groups,
you can define two different origins
and CloudFront will try to fetch the data
from the first origin.
If the origin will fail to respond,
for example, giving HTTP 500 or 400,
CloudFront will auto
retry to the second region
and this is without your
clients to be aware of it.
So this is like a native
failover mechanism
over at CloudFront.
So how it is all going
to be connected together
and how the architecture
is going to be changed?
So we are going to introduce a new router,
we called it a traffic router.
So as I mentioned this is happens
after the WAF but before our origins.
And this will allow us
to create this custom mechanism
that our business needs.
So when a request will hit the CloudFront,
we'll get first to WAF.
Now if WAF detects a bot,
it will add the same header
that sneak added before,
but instead of just going to the cache,
now this this new header
is exposable within CloudFront Functions
and we're going to implement
change the origin to all the bots
and for 1% of the bots we're
going to eliminate the caching.
So as I mentioned before, you
can do 1% or more than that.
And of course after it
we'll redirect the traffic to the cache.
Let's see it in action.
So in order to associate,
oh, one second.
In order to associate a
function for CloudFront,
you will need to choose your behavior.
If you scroll down in the behaviors,
you will have four different hooks
where you can associate
a functional lambda edge.
I'm going to associate it
for the viewer request.
I'm going to choose a custom function
and I'm going to choose a
function that's a pre-made.
We'll see the code in a second.
I just deployed very quickly
and this is all you need to do in order
to have compute turning on the Edge.
So let's check the actual code
and how we implemented
the different aspect
that we see for CloudFront Function.
Okay, so this is basically the end there,
those 20 lines.
So first I extracted the
request from the event.
This is the request and
this is the headers.
I have created my own
is bot detected function
that's checking on the headers.
Let's see, this function
is just right here
and this is a simple function.
It's simply to check if the WAF header
that we've added before
that is equal for true.
Meaning this scope of code
will only run for bots.
So for our users that are human users,
this altogether will be skipped.
For bots we are going
to randomize a number
between zero and 100
and only for 1% of the traffic,
we're going to implement a cache busting.
But again we can do it 50%
and do some kind of maybe test for it.
The way that I have
implemented the cache busting
is randomize a new value
and override the header
that's according to it the
cache policy is working.
So from caching perspective,
each time that we're
randomizing the number,
it's seeing that this is all new request
and it's keeping the caching.
And last on row 24,
I've used the method of
select request origin by ID
and I've used an ID of my origin
that I pre-created for the bot.
I'm going to copy paste the ID here
and let's see where it's being configured.
So I'm going back to the
CloudFront distribution.
So I can see in the origin tabs
I now have the ID that I've used before
and this is a lambda function URL.
So you can create your own origin pre-made
having them deployed and simply map them
in CloudFront Functions using the ID.
So let's see together
how it impacted our platform.
So I am currently a
regular human, I hope so,
and I'm searching for pets
and everything is working as expected.
And the moment that I'm
switching to be a bot,
I started to get a bot pets
and for sure those bot pets
are not going to be impacted
if any kind of bot will
try to adopt them, right?
You can also check it out
with using your mobile phone.
This is the URL from before
and hopefully you will see
the same different bots that I see.
So checking out the network here
you will see that the response
are hits from CloudFront,
this means it's being cached
but only 1% of this
traffic is being cached.
So if I'm going to check the admin panel,
I have a couple of logs already here
and as I mentioned, we are
not just going to respond
a different response to the bot.
We want to fetch some
information about those bots.
So we created a simple login UI
and as you can see we
have now the information
on the route the bot tried to hit,
the bot IP, the different user agents.
So we see some of those are
using in this example PhantomJS,
but some of those are using
an actual user agents.
We have the JA fingerprint and so,
and this is all the metadata
that I wanted to implement.
Let's see how it impacts our CloudWatch.
So I'm going to the honeypot routing,
let's refresh it.
I'm going to do the last 50 minutes.
Okay.
So we can see here that our
cache hit rate decreased a bit
and this has happened because
now 1% of the bot traffic
are having cache miss.
But we introduced a new function,
it might be a bit too small
but on the third row you have,
we have the honeypot Lambda invocation
and you can see it being
hit like, four times.
So for all the traffic that
we are sending for the bots,
only four bots, we actually
got hit by the whole region.
- I'll switch.
- Thank you.
And here we have a more
simplified way to look at it.
So the vast majority of our
metrics remain the same.
We have the same amount of
requests coming to the system.
We have almost the same caching hit rate
because only 1% of the
traffic is being cache missed.
And this is by purpose thanks
to our CloudFront Functions
and we introduced only a very
small amount of new lambda
that's being served new
content to the bots.
So the cost impact for it is
going to be very, very minimal.
And this is also can be adjusted.
So if you want a less percent than one,
you can also do half percent
of the traffic is being cache busting.
So this is highly customized
for your own business needs
and as always, this is not enough.
We wanted more,
so we thought how we can get
any new insight for our bots?
So instead of just to respond a new JSON,
a new patch to our bots,
we want to respond and
images to the bots, right?
And as we saw in the
platform the images, sorry.
The images are being
rendered with the browser.
So we thought how cool
it can be if the browser
that's rendering the images
will send us new metrics
and then we can correlate between the bots
that's making the fetch
request of the APIs
and the bot that's actually
are being rendering our images.
So even here in our static routes,
which usually is just being used
for caching and proxy to S3,
we introduce a new CloudFront function.
And this CloudFront
function is quite simple.
All it's going to do
is when bot is going to render an image,
the CloudFront Functions are going
to do an ASN console log
and ship the metadata to CloudWatch logs
and then respond the same image
so the bots doesn't even know
that something happened
behind the scenes for them.
Yeah, let's see it in the demo.
So as before,
if I want to associate a new function,
I'm going back to my distribution
then to my behaviors.
Now I am going to check
a different behavior,
which is the static PNG's path.
I'm going to add this
new function and save it.
Let's see the function code itself,
it's going to be either
simplified than the previous one.
So let's see here.
So this is my header on
the first three lines,
I'm extracting the request metadata
and then it simply comes log of JSON
with all the information from the request.
That is important for me as a
business to better understand
and better analyze the
traffic that is coming.
So in this case we want
to make a correlation
between the search request
and the image request.
So I log the same metadata
such as the user agent and the client IP,
but also JA fingerprint
that is being pre-calculated
by CloudFront.
So they're getting it
out of free of charge
within all the requests.
I also console log the device type.
So again I can know if
it's a desktop, mobile,
iOS, Android, et cetera.
And I also have the get location.
And again this can be highly customized
by our own business needs.
So I'm getting back to the platform.
I'm doing requests as a normal human,
everything is working fine
and then I'm switching to bots
and still those bots
are being responsed by their own images.
But each time that this image
is being rendered in the console,
now we should have a log for it.
Let's see if it's already
fetched some logs, yeah.
So I will zoom in a bit.
So you can see that instead
of just having my API log,
now I have the log for the bots images.
So I can see that it's
a different client IPs
that are actually rendering the data
versus the kind of IPs
that are fetching our APIs.
Same goes to the user
agents, same goes to the ASN,
sorry, and the JA fingerprints.
So this makes us understand
that there is a machine probably
that's making the request
and fetching the API for us.
But this machine is trying
to publish our content across the globe
and there is actual browsers out there
that are rendering the image.
So we can do,
now we can even do our rough rules
even more complex than that
because if we see a JA fingerprint
that is repeated as a rendered image
or maybe as a API search,
we can now block this
specific JA fingerprint
or maybe create a new rate limit.
So basically we just expose
many more metrics out there,
thank you.
Many more metrics
and give your business the ability
to control the traffic accordingly.
We thought it will be best
to simplify a bit the architecture.
I saw many of you taking
pictures of the architecture
that we just showcased and this is great,
but we want to talk about
the high level concept
because every different product
is built a bit differently.
So we want to to discuss
how you can implement it
with your own business.
So we used WAF in our case in
order to label the traffic,
unlike the vast majority
of the usage of WAF,
which is blocking.
And if you use WAF for labeling,
now you have the upstream
that can react to it.
So we use CloudFront
Functions to react to it.
But if you have your honor
regions behind the scenes,
your origin can be exposed
to those labels as well.
Within the CloudFront
Functions we use modified.
So now the CloudFront Functions knew
if it's a bot or not a bot
and could react differently to those.
After the modification,
some of the traffic,
99% of the traffic still
got served by the cache
because this is what we
wanted as a business.
But the rest of the 1% got
split into two different regions
and this is like more trivial architecture
that you mostly see in
the different patterns.
But again, you don't need to
replicate it step by step,
just taking different concepts.
So the takeaways that I
want you to take back home
and thinking about your
architecture is split it into three.
First,
and for most you need to be traffic aware.
You should ask yourself do you really know
what goes on within your system?
So in our case we just used
label for bot versus humans,
but this can be for any
business related topic.
So it can be different tenants,
different tenant tiers
like premium or freemium.
This can be even sales,
like if you want to route traffic
from the EU to a EU region,
you can do it using CloudFront.
So rethink within your engineering team
and your product team,
what kind of different metadata
is related to your business.
So we showcased this about bots
but this literally can be anything else.
Second, simplify.
All the changes
that Nick and myself done
during this live demo
was done only using
CloudFront and AWS WAF.
We haven't introduced any
change to our application.
So you can think how
much of your complexity
you can move to the Edge
without actually impacting
your engineering efforts.
So rethink, if there is maybe workload
that's you're currently
doing in your own regions
that's you can simplify and
decouple it to run on the Edge.
And last, create a synergy.
Using AWS Services is not
just selecting one component
and use just it.
In our use cases we used WAF,
CloudFront Functions and CloudFront Cache.
So rethink about to each
one of those components
what value it brings to you.
And now you can multiply this value
by connecting all those
components together.
This re:Invent session is,
re:Invent week is full of
content delivery sessions.
We have packed all of them for you
so you can take a screenshot of it.
I know that some of those already passed
but most of them are being recorded
so this can be used later on
when you want to pick
some of those content.
I will keep it here for a second.
Yeah, everyone stopped taking picture.
Moreover, we curated those
three articles for you.
The first two is different articles
that will deep dive into the
concept that we discussed today
about how the flow request is happening
within CloudFront and WAF
and the different approaches
of using origin routing.
And the last QR is actually
about a pricing change
that we released two weeks ago.
This is called the
flat-rate pricing plans.
And it goes between $0 a
month up to $1000 a month
and this is a fixed price.
So currently there is,
and you get CloudFront
and WAF out of the box.
So this is give you like a very quick way
to start using those different components
that we just discussed with
a very little price for it
and goes from there.
And my ask for you before
you leave this room
is to do something good
for the pets out there.
So if you'll open the AWS Events up
and feedback this session.
For every feedback we are going to donate
for a pet organization, nonprofit,
nonprofit pet organization.
So we really appreciate
your honest feedback for this session.
This will highly help us later
on to shape this session,
but it will also allow us to
help other pets out there.
So please use our AWS Events
to feedback this session.
And thank you, folks.
How was it all? Nick?
Have a happy re:Invent week.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.